[Music]
I'm gonna get one of those vultures one
day I'm gonna get one I don't know why
it's so important to you
I just feel like you would make me feel
better oh no it's a little lion that is
not alive well then go check out what
it's not a lion it's a furry bird it
looks like a lion it's not let me get a
closer look excuse me all right let me
see what we're dealing with here it's a
lion
it's bigger can we eat them can we
please keep him oh I promise I'll walk
in every day if he makes a little mess
I'll clean it up you'll be his little
mess he's gonna eat you and then use my
body as a toothpick but one day when
he's big and strong he'll be on our side
I've got it what if he's on our side
hear me out having a ferocious line
around might not be such a bad idea
well then can we keep him yes of course
we can keep it well God who is the
brains of this operation we're gonna
name him Fred
life's not fair
is it my little friend while some are
born to feast others spend their lives
in the dark
[Music]
begging for scraps
everything you see
exist together in a delicate balance
[Music]
while others search for what they can
take a true king searches for what he
can do
[Music]
December and never return
you must take your place
and the circle of life
[Music]